good afternoon all and Thank You mr.
president
the White House coronavirus task force
met today we briefed the president on
our latest recommendations if we
continue at the president's direction to
lead not a whole-of-government approach
but a whole of America approach you just
heard the president describe one
inspiring story after another at the way
the American people are responding the
way American businesses are responding
religious communities across this
country and the American people are
coming together they're responding with
common sense compassion and generosity
people are heeding the advice of state
and local authorities and tens of
millions of Americans are putting into
practice 15 days to slow the spread we
are we are officially mr. president it's
six days into our 15 days and as we look
all across this country while we we
strongly support the decisions that
governors in states where we have
significant outbreak have taken we
encourage every American to listen to
those state and local authorities for
every American this is what you can do
to make a difference over the next week
and a few days to protect your health
protect your family's health but most
especially slow the spread and the
potential for the coronavirus to impact
the most vulnerable as the president
said we we've been we've almost been
overwhelmed at the outpouring of support
from American businesses the president
spoke yesterday to thousands of small
businesses we spoke to manufacturers
yesterday and in fact as the president
indicated the FDA in in record time just
approved one manufacturer that will be
producing millions of surgical masks in
a matter of weeks for the American
people the pastors we spoke to we we
want to thank all the religious leaders
from every community of faith in the
country making a hard choice to suspend
services to have
online services even while those
ministries are continuing to support
food banks and come alongside the most
vulnerable and of course the chorus of
prayers that is coming up from
communities of faith around the country
is making the difference that it always
has in the life of this nation one thing
the president and I promised was to
remind people that on the the weekends
that you're not in the pews it's still
the good it's still a good idea to if
you can to go ahead and make that
donation continue because all the
ministries are continuing to play a
vital role in our communities and we
encourage your continued support the
President and I are grateful that the
American people are listening to state
and local authorities and and putting
into practice all of all of the
recommendations in the president's
coronavirus guidelines and as you will
hear in just a few moments from Admiral
Gua testing is expanding rapidly across
the United States of America state-run
drive-throughs are expanding across the
country and as you will hear detail this
morning now more than a hundred and
ninety-five thousand Americans and more
who have been symptomatic have been
tested that number does not include
County hospitals or or health care labs
around the nation some 15,000 in number
and among the number of the more than a
hundred 95,000 that have been tested
it's important to remember that only
19,000 343 at this moment have tested
positive for the corona virus we want to
we continue to urge state and local
health authorities to contact FEMA for
all the latest developments and
innovations in testing but we want to
remind Americans as dr. Fauci will
emphasize in a moment if you don't have
symptoms don't do a test it is another
way that the American people can make
sure that we are preserving the
resources that our health care workers
need to minister and to support those
who are dealing with the corona virus
and other illnesses in a moment
Pete Gaynor will detail the efforts at
FEMA since the president's national
emergency declaration we have FEMA in
the lead stood up the National Response
Coordination Center as the president
said and we are working closely
literally hour by hour through FEMA
processing requests from state's most
impacted like New York Washington State
and California and will continue and to
work very very closely with those states
through the very traditional means of
Federal Emergency Management at FEMA
secretary Carson will describe decisive
actions the president alluded to to
bring foreclosure relief to Americans
and on the subject of supplies in a
moment you will hear of not only the
progress that we're making on testing
but on Monday we'll be detailing for the
American people the progress that we are
making on the president's strategy of
procuring more personal protective
equipment and medical supplies
allocating them through the system of
FEMA and continuing to urge the
conservation by Americans in fact I'm
pleased to report to the president today
that HHS just placed an order for
hundreds of millions of n95 masks that
will be being made available to health
care providers across the country on
behalf of the president we do renew our
call for Americans to postpone elective
medical procedures including dental
services and remember this is another
way that you're going to make sure that
medical supplies are available because
by postponing elective medical
procedures you're freeing up medical
supplies for those dealing with the
corona virus as the president mentioned
our team is on Capitol Hill as we speak
working with members of Congress in both
political parties they're making
progress
by all accounts on a bipartisan bill
they worked late into the night last
night started early this morning and we
are working to pass that legislation on
Monday in both the House and the Senate
now on a personal note many of you may
have been made aware that a member of
my staff has tested positive for the
corona virus we learned of that late
yesterday I am pleased to report that he
is doing well
he had mild cold like symptoms for about
a day and a half has not been to the
White House since Monday neither the
president nor I had direct contact with
that staff person
we worked immediately with a White House
physician and the CDC we've done all
contact tracing and while the White
House doctor has indicated that he has
no reason to believe that I was exposed
and no need to be tested given the
unique position that I have as vice
president and as the leader of the White
House coronavirus task force both I and
my wife will be tested for the corona
virus later this afternoon let me say
again how grateful the President and I
are that every American has acted on the
president's coronavirus guidelines we
are six days into 15 days that as dr.
Fauci may well reflect in a moment is an
opportunity for us here on the foot
holes of this epidemic curve in our
country to literally lower the impact in
our nation and save lives every American
can do their part to slow the spread and
we encourage you to continue to do that
as the president says often remember
we're all in this together and also
remember that that for for most
Americans their risk of serious illness
from the corona virus remains low the
reason we want to put into practice the
president's coronavirus guidelines is
because no American would want to
inadvertently expose someone who is
vulnerable a senior with a serious
underlying health condition to the
corona virus with a potential threat I
did hear one story this morning mr.
president about a senior named Jennifer
wood she actually is at the Life Care
Center in Kirkland Washington she is not
only a grandmother she is a great-great
grandmother 90 years young and she
tested positive for the corona virus on
March 6 but by all accounts she's doing
well and she wanted America
no there is hope and her strength in her
enthusiasm is truly an inspiration to
the nation as the president said many
times we're gonna get through this and
come out stronger than ever before and
we'll get through this as Americans
together Thank You mr. president